llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniela blandón daniela
muy buena noche bienvenida 20 millones
de personas cayeron en situación de
hambre en todo el mundo durante el año
azul 20
así es raúl muy buenas noches pues mira
el número de personas en condición de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda en 2020
alcanzó un máximo desde que iniciaron
los registros en 2017 esto según un
informe de la organización de la
agricultura y la alimentación de
naciones unidas el cubit 19 los
conflictos armados y el clima son los
que principalmente la originan
escucharnos
y lo que sorprende es que 10 países y
territorios tenían 103 millones de 255
millones de personas con hambre lo que
significa que más del 65% de las
personas con inseguridad alimentaria
estaban sólo en 10 países república
democrática del congo yemen afganistán
siria sudán el norte de nigeria etiopía
sudán del sur
zimbabwe y haití
[Música]
pues será un mire el la fao distingue
por fases 155 millones de personas en 55
países padecían hambre al cierre del año
otros 28,4 millones estaban en situación
de emergencia y 133 mil ya tenían una
condición demasiado extrema llamada
hambruna lamentable esta noticia daniela
pero continuamos la producción
industrial de brasil retrocedió en el
mes de marzo
tampoco alentador falso sí señor así es
pues mire el que es uno de los grandes
países industriales de américa latina
tuvo en marzo su segunda caída en la
producción después de una racha de nueve
meses consecutivos al alza el descenso
fue del 2,4 por ciento respecto al mes
anterior no obstante si se compara con
el mismo mes del año pasado cuando se
paralizó la economía se reportó un
crecimiento del 10,5 por ciento lo que
más se está afectando en este momento la
producción industrial brasileña es la
poca actividad automotriz también la
confección de vestuario y lo relacionado
con cueros y calzado y en eeuu declaran
inválida la moratoria de desalojos por
cuenta de la pandemia
paula el año pasado bajo
administración de donald trump fueron
prohibidos los desalojos de quienes no
tuvieron con que pagar su renta y el
presidente joe biden lo extendió hasta
el 30 de junio la medida aplicada para
quienes reciben subsidio de la
administración federal y los inquilinos
que ganaron menos de 99 mil dólares en
2020 una jueza del tribunal del distrito
federal en washington declaró inválida
esa moratoria porque cree que los
centros para el control de prevención y
enfermedades excedieron sus funciones
cuando la decretaron el fallo es una
victoria para una coalición de
propietarios de viviendas que rechazaba
esta medida daniela y la mayor
productora de guantes quirúrgicos del
mundo fue acusada de trabajo forzoso se
llama top load corp que es una empresa
de malasia que produce alrededor de una
cuarta parte del suministro mundial de
guantes de goma cuya demanda se disparó
por supuesto por la pandemia
eeuu a través de su oficina de aduanas
incautó un envío de casi 4 millones de
guantes tras acusar a la firma de
ejercer trabajo forzoso en un comunicado
dice la entidad que no tolerará está
esclavitud moderna que daña a los
trabajadores vulnerables y amenaza a la
economía entre las denuncias que han
recibido están por ejemplo que hay
empleados que pagan deudas con trabajo
uso excesivo de horas extras condiciones
de trabajo abusivas y retención de
documentos de identidad trabajo
increíble qué pasa en estas cosas en
estos tiempos a nivel indicadores o
street end cerró mixto pero las acciones
de las farmacéuticas se desplomaron
después de que eeuu dijera que apoyo era
la liberación de patentes de las vacunas
para que más países puedan producirlas
como vemos en el gráfico raúl las
acciones europeas marcaron su mejor día
en casi dos meses después de los datos
que mostraron una recuperación de la
actividad industrial en la zona euro y
en américa latina la bolsa de buenos
aires volvió a terreno positivo después
de una mala racha de tres jornadas
daniela por favor la cifra al día bueno
mal esperemos que sea una bueno a
algunos les conviene a otros no son tres
mil 846 pesos este es el valor del dólar
hoy en colombia después de alcanzar su
segundo pico más alto en lo que va del
año en medio de las marchas
antigubernamentales la incertidumbre
política y económica genera una fuga de
capitales que a su vez aumenta la
demanda de dólares y por eso la moneda
pierde valor el diario local la
repubblica dice que la colombiana es la
moneda emergente que más se ha devaluado
en lo corrido del año por encima del
peso argentino y de la lira turca
gracias ala por toda la información de
ustedes gracias buena noche
[Música]